[Aplausos]
como le vamos a hacer para mantenernos
unidos en estos tiempos de división
en méxico estamos viviendo en los
momentos más divididos y más polarizados
que al menos yo recuerdo en la elección
que acabamos de pasar los ataques sean
un tema diario y desafortunadamente no
era nada más entre los candidatos sino
también entre nosotros los ciudadanos es
más hasta el día de hoy seguimos
escuchando esos ataques unos le dicen
precisan los otros
ellos le responden que son los caidos y
así cada vez van subiendo de nivel los
ataques
es cierto que no somos el único país que
está pasando por esta situación podemos
ver el ejemplo de brasil o el ejemplo de
eeuu para darnos cuenta que está
fragmentación social es algo que está
pasando en todo el mundo sin embargo
este méxico dividido no es el méxico en
el que yo quisiera vivir y yo creo que
los jóvenes tenemos mucho por hacer para
asegurarnos de que haya mucho más unión
y podamos erradicar esta división que
estamos viviendo pero bueno antes de
platicarles de lo que yo creo que
podríamos hacer los jóvenes quisiera
contarles un poco más de mi vida y el
camino que me llevo de la ciudad de
durango a hacer la carrera en harvard y
a más recientemente a una maestría en la
que también tuve la oportunidad y el
honor de ser el presidente de este grupo
de mexicanos en la universidad que se
llama o más
entonces bien todo empieza en el año
2000 yo tenía 12 años y bien primero de
secundaria y por azares del destino ahí
en mi colegio aparecieron los papeles de
la universidad en un tríptico un libro
chiquito que hablaba acerca de la
universidad de las clases que ofrecía
tenía fotos de las aulas de los salones
de los edificios y el equipo de remo
algo entro en mí y me di cuenta que ahí
es donde yo quería estar desde ese
momento se convirtió para mí en un sueño
el poder ir a harvard y quería hacer
todo lo que estuviera en mis manos para
lograr ese sueño
lo primero que hice fue ir con un
director que era especialista en temas
de admisiones y le conté mi sueño
yo quería su ayuda para entender que
tenía que hacer a través de secundaria y
a través de la prepa para tener una
buena aplicación y así poder ser
aceptado en esta universidad
desafortunadamente su reacción no pudo
haber sido peor
él se rió y me dijo sacas de este sueño
a la cabeza es algo casi imposible para
alguien de eeuu para alguien de méxico
es impensable enfócate en algo más busca
algo diferente pero eso no es para ti
imagínense tener 12 años que es como tú
buscas que alguien te apoye ya que si se
puede y que un maestro que le sabía este
tema me dijera que no iba a ser posible
la verdad para mí fue una gran decepción
y pasaron meses en los que yo realmente
no empecé a hacer nada al respecto
porque pensaba pues que tenía razón que
no se va a poder afortunadamente con el
apoyo de mi familia y de gente en mi
escuela que sí creyeron en mí fui
haciendo todo lo que se puede hacer para
hacer una aplicación buena y con eso
lanzar el proceso en prepa en serio tuve
que hacer de todo lo que se imaginen una
vez me tocó cantar como juanes aquí
tengo unos amigos que se acuerdan estaba
aquí en el equipo de basketball como
pueden ver no era muy bueno que digamos
pero pude echaba ganas y en temas un
poco más positivos también me tocó hace
un diccionario que pasábamos palabras de
español e inglés y que lo traducimos a
braille para poder dárselo a una escuela
en durango que era de niños invidentes y
que así ellos podían ir aprendiendo
inglés a través de este diccionario en
fin agarré toda esta todas estas
experiencias hice los ensayos de
aplicación mandé toda la universidad y
no
pero el resultado ya en 2005 llegó un
mail de la universidad yo estaba en un
viaje de estudios y tenía muy poca
conexión a internet por lo mismo le tocó
mi mamá el abrir ese mail y entonces ya
lo abre yo estaba en el teléfono y me
dice no no no no y así no queda más no
no no no y ha sido un día por favor me
dice te aceptaban a hardware
fue un momento que hasta el día me sigo
acordando en una forma muy emotiva y que
en ese momento me hizo entender que todo
ese proceso en la secundaria y en la
prepa los momentos difíciles habían
valido la pena
yo pensé erróneamente que ya lo difícil
había pasado que ahora sí va a poder
llegar a la universidad y a poder
disfrutar y quedar así y va a ser lo que
yo tanto pensaba desafortunadamente ya
cuando llegué a la universidad fue algo
bastante difícil ese primer semestre me
toca abandonar a mi familia a mi ciudad
a mi país llegue un lugar en el que la
gente estaba muy bien preparada yo
llegaban las clases y la verdad que no
entendía lo que estaban platicando y
empecé incluso reprobando varias clases
también bueno pues el frío y la nieve no
creo que me ayudaron mucho y hubieron
tiempos en los que yo en serio pensé en
renunciar
afortunadamente ahí conoció un grupo de
mexicanos que trabajaban en este equipo
que se llamaba aún más quienes me
abrieron las puertas a su organización y
me invitaron a ser uno más de su equipo
ellos me dieron a entender que méxico no
estaba tan lejos de mí que si ayer había
mexicanos esos mexicanos nos podemos
unir para poder representar la mejor
manera a nuestro país en nuestra
comunidad y poco a poco yo les empecé a
ayudar y me empecé a sentir más en casa
en la universidad una de las cosas que
hicimos fue un evento del día de los
muertos que básicamente en cada una las
escuelas de la universidad montamos un
altar e invitamos a todos los
estudiantes americanos europeos
africanos para que lo vieran y vivían
nuestra tradición y esto fue muchos años
atrás antes de que se le ocurriera algo
de coco entonces un poquito más difícil
pero pues fue una forma en la que
pudimos demostrar cómo era nuestra
cultura en méxico y que así también
nosotros nos sintamos más integrados en
la universidad
pasaron los años y en 2009 por fin pude
agarrar ese diploma que me acreditaba
como uno más de los graduados de esa
universidad que para mí había sido un
sueño desde chiquito yo estando en esa
ceremonia graduación me di cuenta que el
apoyo de este grupo el apoyo de un más
fue fundamental para que yo pudiera
pasar los momentos más difíciles y
pudiera llegar a esa graduación de la
mejor manera fue ahí cuando me hice una
promesa a mí mismo si yo pudiera
regresar hacer una maestría iba a hacer
todo lo posible por ser presidente de
esta organización y de esa manera tal
vez tener un impacto tan positivo como
lo tuvo en mí mismo en ese año
ya después de pasar unos años y voy a
trabajar a eeuu lo ve bien en mexico y
decía aplicar la maestría y entré
afortunadamente a la escuela de negocios
para hacer un envío casi desde el inicio
mi misión fue armar un equipo
competitivo con el cual pudiera
participar en las elecciones de umas y
totanés el presidente de esta gran
organización
como les cuento que se convirtió en una
de las elecciones más competidas que
había habido en años y que incluso la
universidad se tuvo que meter como un
árbitro independiente para
y todos los ataques que nos estábamos
echando entre nosotros todas las
descalificaciones todo lo complicado que
estaba pasando la universidad se tuvo
que meter para controlarnos imagínense
todo esto por un grupo estudiantil y más
un grupo que debería representar a
méxico
pasaron las elecciones llegaron los
resultados y habíamos ganado por cuatro
votos de 200 personas que habían votado
por fuera yo estaba feliz se ha cumplido
esta promesa que me he hecho a mi mismo
hace años y además lo estaba haciendo
con un grupo de amigos que ven ahí que
eran gente que yo admiraba mucho y que
yo estaba seguro que vamos a poder hacer
una buena labor por la comunidad
mexicana y en boston
por dentro yo estaba triste yo estaba
decepcionado que había sido partícipe de
generar esa división en un grupo en un
grupo que para mí había significado
mucho fueron momentos bastante difíciles
en los que yo no sabía realmente cómo le
a poder dar la vuelta a esta situación
pero bueno junte a mi equipo empezamos a
practicar y empezamos a buscar ideas en
las cuales pudiéramos agarrar esto que
estaba dividido y darle la vuelta para
tener un grupo más unido y que
representara bien a todos los
estudiantes y fuimos haciendo varias
cosas
miren los cuentos lo primero que hicimos
fue ir a hablar con el equipo al que le
acabamos de ganar para entender de ellos
todas sus críticas sus reclamos su enojo
porque era muy importante que les
demostramos que vamos a ser un grupo que
iba a escuchar las críticas y que iba
estar abierto a tomar todas las
recomendaciones que la gente podía tener
lo segundo fue que con esa gente que
estuvo más interesada en ayudarnos
empezamos a ver qué actividad les
interesaban cuáles eran sus
preocupaciones y que de su agenda
podíamos incluir en nuestro plan de
trabajo para así que nuestro grupo
pudiera hacer las actividades no nada
más que prometimos en la campaña sino
también las actividades que fueran
importantes para todos los estudiantes
lo tercero nos pusimos a trabajar
era muy muy importante que le
mostráramos a todos los que no hayan
votado por nosotros y que no hayan
funcionado en nuestra planilla el que sí
habíamos hecho todo ese proceso de la
elección era porque estábamos
convencidos que podíamos algo importante
por los mexicanos en la universidad y
empezamos a hacer una serie de
actividades que poco a poco fueron
ganando la confianza de la gente ahí
ustedes pueden ver algunas pero por
ejemplo cada vez que juega la selección
hacíamos una noche de fútbol muchas
veces en mi departamento
llevamos conferencistas ex presidentes
senadores secretarios de estado y
también un más organizaba una fiesta de
independencia que era así la principal
de todo boston y lo organizamos nosotros
en esta fiesta de independencia me tocó
dar el grito que para mí es una de las
cosas que siempre me voy a acordar de
toda mi experiencia ya en la universidad
y que eso me dio entender y me hizo
darme cuenta que poco a poco nos estamos
uniendo más como grupo y como equipo
también tuvimos temas más complejos por
ejemplo en ese año fue cuando ganó trump
y obviamente con todos los ataques a los
mexicanos los estudiantes los golpearon
a ver a nosotros para ver cómo íbamos a
responder y demostrar a esta nueva
administración que los mexicanos tenemos
mucho que aportar no nada más los que
tenemos el privilegio de estudiar allá
sino también todos los inmigrantes que
estaban viviendo en boston y otras
partes de eeuu
poco a poco con estas actividades fuimos
ganando la confianza de toda la gente
mexicana en la universidad y cuando
terminó el año yo creo que entregamos
una organización que era más fuerte más
unida y con mejores bases para que todos
los mexicanos que sigan entrando a la
universidad puedan tener la experiencia
que yo tuve desde que estaba chico
y bien no les cuento esto para insinuar
que lo que nos tocó vivir en este grupo
estudiantil compara con el gran reto que
tenemos hacia adelante aquí en méxico
aquí en méxico estamos en un momento en
el cual tenemos que empezar a unirnos
los jóvenes y empezar a evitar toda la
división y yo estoy viendo al menos en
diferentes comunidades yo no creo que lo
que nos pasó en este grupo sea
comparable pero sí creo que hay
enseñanzas y hay lecciones que podemos
aprovechar para empezar a fomentar más
la unidad que tanto necesitamos lo
principal es que tenemos que empezar a
escuchar a aquellos que no piensan como
nosotros
si alguno de ustedes tiene un amigo que
voto por alguien que ustedes no
comparten o que no están de acuerdo
hablen con ellos
pregúntenles que los llevó a votar por
esa opción oa tomar esa decisión
mejor aún salgan de su zona de confort
vayan a otras escuelas vayan a otras
comunidades incluso si pueden vayan a
otras ciudades y platiquen con jóvenes
que no viven en las mismas
circunstancias que ustedes viven estoy
seguro de que si lo hacen se van a dar
cuenta que lo que tal vez ahorita nos
divide es poco porque al final los
objetivos a largo plazo y los sueños que
tenemos todos los jóvenes aquí en méxico
son los mismos y para nuestro país ese
sueño no puede ser otro que el tener un
país más próspero equitativo y unido
ya demostramos hace un año que podemos
trabajar juntos y todo lo que podemos
lograr cuando los jóvenes nos unimos
el 19 de septiembre del año pasado nos
tocó vivir uno de los días más trágicos
que ha tenido nuestro país al menos en
tiempos recientes
para todos nosotros que no estamos vivos
en el 85 nos tocó vivir un sismo que nos
hizo dar cuenta lo vulnerables que
podemos ser que hay comunidades muy
cercanas donde vivimos nosotros que
están en una situación muy desfavorecida
y que son los que más sufren en estos en
estos eventos trágicos
que un sismo como este te puede cambiar
y te puede dar mucha inseguridad como
país
al mismo tiempo este sismo nos demostró
los fuertes que también podemos ser y
como si los jóvenes trabajamos juntos
hay mucho que se puede lograr incluso
más que un gobierno que sea pasivo ante
estas tragedias yo estoy seguro que
muchos de ustedes fueron a los lugares
donde ocurrió el sismo para ver cómo
podían ayudar apalancar las redes
sociales para ver cómo se puedan
comunicar mejor y buscaron la forma en
la cual podían y podíamos tener un
impacto
ya pasó una vez ya demostramos que los
jóvenes juntos tenemos mucho que aportar
a este país
no esperemos a la siguiente tragedia
para volver a trabajar juntos
en mi punto de vista estamos pasando por
un momento trascendental en la historia
de méxico en los siguientes años se va a
definir si vamos a hacer un país
innovador un país que mira hacia el
futuro un país que adopte las mejores
tecnologías de alrededor del mundo para
generar todo el desarrollo y el
crecimiento que necesitamos en nuestro
país en los siguientes años se va a
definir si queremos ser un país
vanguardista o un país que se queda
estancado en el pasado los jóvenes
tenemos que participar en esa decisión
a través de los siguientes años los
jóvenes entre 18 y 35 años pero que
puede incluir gente que se sienta joven
de corazón vamos a hacer el bloque más
importante en el país y nuestra voz
debería ser escuchada yo lo que los
invito y les propongo es que empecemos a
unirnos en asociaciones civiles en
grupos en sus universidades incluso en
plataformas políticas que le abran
lugares a los jóvenes para empezar a
trabajar conjuntamente yo estoy seguro
de que si los jóvenes nos unimos con una
agenda en común con una visión a futuro
podemos lograr el méxico que todos
queremos ese medio que sea más próspero
un méxico más equitativo un méxico más
unido
si se puede claro que se puede ir juntos
lo vamos a lograr muchas gracias
[Aplausos]